Yvette Nicole Brown was on the blue
carpet to celebrate season three of Ted
lasso that's where I met up with Jason
Sudeikis who basically told me
co-parenting with Olivia Wilde is much
better and that's good news for Otis and
Daisy do they get all this and know how
hard Daddy's working to like bring us
more dad last I don't know if they know
how hard they know how often
[Laughter]
May any of us get the opportunity to
find a job where you have so much fun
doing it and if that's the example that
myself and Olivia you know provide for
them then I you know I'm happy about
that
[Music]
I don't think I ever could have
portrayed a parent in a way that I would
have believed until becoming one without
having you know that kind of love
and hello Hannah waddingham gorgeous and
sharing the next show she wants to be on
Abbott Elementary I thought that I could
be an absolutely revolting
English person that comes in I love I
look I want it to happen can we make
that happen please please
please have a giant lady in your show
before that can happen it's all about
Ted lasso Brett Goldstein and Phil
dunster stunned us with a rumor about
the new season premiering March 15th
he's joked that he plans to kill off a
lot of people in season three Deuce does
someone really die I said five
characters I didn't say they all day I
just had five if you've been watching
the show there are enough to lose there
you should have seen that from the
get-go right jump oh Roxanne just said
great job if people are not satisfied by
the finale I will take myself off to the
woods and you'll never ever see me again
I've been Brett Goldstein this has been
an ET exclusive thank you for watching
come back next week where I'll be
interviewing the surviving members of
deadlasses season three
foreign